a huge debate over censorship who gets
to be the Arbiter of Truth New York
Governor Kathy hokel announcing that her
state will develop our state will
develop a media literacy toolkit to help
school children identify quote unquote
misinformation posted online it's in
response to arise in hate speech against
Jewish and Muslim communities on social
media just look at what happened this
week a prominent message shared on Tik
Tok was one from none other than the
Mastermind of the 911 Massac of
thousands of New Yorkers Osama Bin
Laden it was shocking to see young
people extoling the virtues of a Terrace
pink Kingpin this will teach students
and even teachers to help understand how
to spot conspiracy theories and
misinformation disinformation and online
hate Governor hok's team promises the
toolkit will be ideologically neutral
and California governor Gavin Newsome is
coming under Fire for falsely claiming a
city in Tennessee is banned being gay in
public the town had a law in place that
dated back to 1949 against indecent
exposure in public the original Law
mentioned homosexuality specifically it
was updated just this October and no
longer mentions the word despite the
update taken place nearly a month ago
Governor Newsome tweeted this just days
ago quote a city in Tennessee is banned
being gay in public this is just the
beginning we have to call this out so
two points there um um Greg did the
first point
dis the the bin Lon thing clearly is
disinformation I think we can all agree
that it gets grer as you as people begin
to think about their own feelings and
politics and I want you to come want you
to comment on a governor knew something
too because I have a followup about
about that whether or not uh you know he
knew the truth you got to be really
stupid to think that was real like yeah
you know the state just banned being gay
in public how dumb are you that dumb and
he's going to be the next Democratic
presidential candidate um I think that
the B Len letter is a is not the best
example for this what you're seeing here
is how you're evolving hate speech into
disinformation which means you're
broadening the target for persecution
right this was predicted once you start
with hate hate SP speech one side will
corrupt it and they get to Define what
hate speech is that it becomes something
that disagrees with them so if they say
if the left says X and you disprove X
they will then say you can't say X so
we'll take you off the map that is why
when Elon Musk bought Twitter and turned
it into X it scared the crap out of him
because now he took that strategy of of
marginalizing other people's opinions as
disinformation off the table uh but now
disinformation can include anything from
the you know stuff on covid vaccines
Hunter's laptop and even atrocities in
Gaza so it's like the supporters for
disinformation are too stupid to notice
that the pendulum will swing back who's
ever in control can call the shots so
it's his best not to do this especially
since you saw the what was it the
disinformation department turned out
they were the biggest offenders they
always are judge I agree with Greg the
part about the great part where I can't
get my arms around we can all agree that
the bin Laden thing was wrong how how
should schools deal with it I give the
governor some credit for thinking about
this she might be you don't give her
credit for thinking about it I don't
agree that uh that young kids been the
judge I'm going come to you in one
second I call the why you speak for me I
got to speak up I didn't I said judge I
said judge I didn't say Joey judge I
thought I was in we all
sorry I'm sorry all right look he this
is what I think I think that uh I give
hok credit for recognizing that the bin
Laden thing that went haywire on Tik Tok
and all the young people started buying
into it uh is something that is clearly
needs to be condemned but when Nina
jankowitz and that whole crew and and uh
um uh what's his name from uh Homeland
Security decided they wanted to create a
disinformation board that's when you
know it's the worst and when they say
hokel says I want the teachers to be in
charge of this I want teachers between K
and 12 to be able to spot information
and tell our children what the truth is
and not our kids are already being
indoctrinated the last thing we want is
for teachers to be in charge of this and
the the the Curious Thing is that it was
Randy reinart last week who said GE I
don't understand why so many kids are
being homeschooled well they're being
homeschooled because you're
indoctrinating them you're not teaching
them education so now instead of Reading
Writing arithmetic they're going to be
able to use their own liberal bias or
whatever bias it we don't need to teach
this we need to be able to teach certain
truths and then they can take it from
there I said we all meaning I hope you
can condemn the uh the 911 that's all I
was say you go right ahead though no I I
take issue with the bin Laden letter the
way people reacted to it I mean
everyone at this table in some form or
another has sacrificed because of the
acts of Bin Laden in some way either
through family financially uh just your
peace of mind going to an airport what
happened on 9911 is a big deal I
sacrificed physically but also with time
so I I don't put that on on a scale as
being more or less everyone in this
country should read that letter from Bin
Laden because we should have faith in
our countrymen to discern the difference
between some false flag bull crap
argument on why it's okay to kill
innocent people we we shouldn't be so
afraid that our children and young
people are so stupid and uninformed and
that teachers are so bad at terrible at
their job that they can read propaganda
and and be completely immersed and
influenced by it and if that's the state
of our country then we need to go back
and look at those teachers and ask
people why are you this stupid why are
you this ignorant to what bad people do
it should be a discussion the idea that
we taking this down off platforms it
took me a 30-minute Google search with
good sources to find the letter and read
it again because they're scared to death
that we're that ignorant and that stupid
and that easily impressionable that a
letter from a from a terrorist
Mastermind could influence a whole
generation that's on us that's our
malpractice in raising kids and teaching
people in school everyone should read
that letter and be able to discern the
difference between bull crap and what
actually happened and I just hate that
that's the response and now hok caring
It Forward you know it's the same people
that tear down statues because God
forbid you find out that Robert E Lee
was as complicit in slavery as Thomas
Jefferson but both of them had ideas
worth reading about and understanding
you should understand why someone's so
torn between their federal government
and their state government that they
would decide on the wrong side of War
for it and that it might even be Beyond
just the point of slavery for us to get
into that war and there are so many
things about this country that we should
be so appreciative and thankful this day
as many as any other for the fact we
have a country
and they would just wash it all away and
decolonize Joey
yes do it just make you mad Greg no you
you actually convinced me you con you
completely convinced me because you're
right when I when I was we were doing
that story it was more like it was more
embarrassing than it was angry it wasn't
like it wasn't like I was like mad that
the letter was out I was more
embarrassed by the response to it yeah
so I didn't want to see it the only
thing I was going to say is that new
some was wrong but he doesn't care and
he uses it to try to say okay we need to
have some sort of online fight against
misinformation but that's like asking
Hamas to you know that ask for medical
misinformation to be corrected by in
Gaza it's it's Preposterous does NE and
also pay attention to California like
Tennessee's got it take care of
California got issues of your own we'll
see that next Wednesday Thursday night
with Hannity in the big debate oh yeah
coming up Secretary of Transportation
Budaj attempting to pass the blame on
Thanksgiving travel chaos hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else